[Music]
the mayor that has no guts
is certifiably nuts yeah our city's ripe
with crime but don't mess with our
office time
it was confirmed this week that what
many of us had suspected about chicago
mayor lori lightfoot
she's raving bonkers even jessie smilet
says i find her hard to believe
the chicago tribune obtained an email
she sent to a scheduler back in january
in which she complained she wasn't
getting enough
of what she called office time except
lightfoot repeated several sentences
over and over and over again
like a psychopath it was shocking
when people repeat themselves in chicago
it's usually help help i've been shot
i've been
shot so rather than summarize this email
uh and we are not making this crap up
we're gonna read you the whole thing
just to show you how bat this is take it
away
since my prior requests for office time
are routinely ignored
i am now resorting to this i need office
time
every day i need office time every day i
need office i'm ready i need office time
need all this time every day i need
office time every day i need office time
every day i need all this time every day
i need all this time every day i need
office time every day i need all this
time every day i need office time every
day i need all this time every day i
need office time every day i need all
the time every day
not just once a week or some days but
every day
not just once a week or some days every
day not just once a week or somebody's
every day not just one week or something
every day not just once a week or some
day every day not just once a week or
something every day not just once a week
or some days every day and it's just
once a week sometimes every day and
that's just one single week or some days
already not just once a week or some
days every day
breaks or transitions between meetings
are not
office time breakthrough transition
times between two meetings are not
obviously institutions they're sometimes
redominates are not office time breaks
for transition times between meanings
are not office time breakthrough
transition times between meetings are
not office time research transition time
through means are not office time breaks
are transition times between meetings
are not obvious time
if this doesn't change immediately i
will just start unilaterally canceling
things
every day if this isn't just immediately
i will just start you know whatever
things are doing
immediately i would just start you don't
want to catch something everybody
doesn't change your mind i was just
starting you don't really cut through
things every day this isn't immediately
i will just start you don't always have
some things every day
have i made myself clear finally have a
mid-muscle clear finally i have a
minimal profile on the mainland
i have the minimum queer finally i
haven't made a cell phone finally have
it made myself clear finally i made
myself clear finally i haven't made
myself clear finally have a movement so
clear finally i have a minimum
i've been making finally have it made
myself clear finally
we had to get emily to do that because
she's the fastest talker
on the planet but endlessly repeating
the same thing
is a sign of mental instability or that
you work for cnn
but i repeat myself anyway on monday she
defended the email
to write an email like that comes um
after a lot of
conversation and boring and frustration
um
we got beyond that and solved the the
challenges were at the heart of that
uh email which was written five plus
months ago so i think we're in
a better place uh a better place
anything is better
than that place but ima imagine
if she expressed as much frustration
about her city's murder rate as she does
about her office time
but in the interest of fairness here's
kat reading one of my recent emails
dear cat since my prior requests on this
are routinely ignored i am now resorting
to this
kill meet as a liar kill meat is a liar
kill meat as a liar kill me as a liar
kill me as a liar i didn't leave that in
the hot tub i didn't leave that in the
hot tub i didn't leave that in the hot
tub i didn't leave that in the hot tub i
didn't leave that in the hot tub
i've been constipated for five days i've
been constipated for five days i've been
constipated for five
days i've been constipated for five days
i've been constipated for five days
have i made myself clear finally
well working for the chicago mayor
doesn't seem so bad
now does it all right cat do i ever do
weird emails
yeah i don't think working on this show
i ever got an
email that was not very strange for
example that one
yes but uh yeah i mean it's weird it's
aggressive i
don't know that it was effective
although i think that just the general
fear that our employees have of her
probably is
uh but on the list of things that i
don't like about
lori that lori lightfoot this is pretty
low yeah
on the list just more so the general way
in which she mayors the city
i'd say is pretty much the worst part
yeah you know uh
james i know there has to be a
correlation between how bad the city
is and what's going on in there because
that email is crazy
she out of three million people she's
the best person in chicago
to take a pic yes and second off i think
she needs less office time
she's afraid to leave her office because
there's been three mass shootings in the
past week
that's true like how do you how do you
and by the way she says her staff's
better
her staff from when she wrote that email
they're all gone now right
quit yeah yeah the person she wrote that
email to has quit the job so
true horse is better now yes they all
left screaming from the building
i don't know if anybody works there
she's by herself in her office now
exactly
she now has her alone time yeah right
exactly oh my god uh
terence um have you ever sent an email
like this
veto juice beetlejuice
so here you have the mayor from hell
sitting in her office writing the same
sentence over
and over right while her city is turning
into gotham
yeah yeah yeah by the way she wrote that
email during her office time exactly
this is absolutely crazy but i have
something for her to do since she likes
to write
write down all of the names of the young
people that are gunned down
weekend after weekend in chicago and
lori lightfoot
start with the name jazlyn adams a
seven-year-old who was shot and killed
in a drive-through start with that name
lori lightfoot
yeah that's a great point
susan it's this was actually i think
this was i'm so glad he does the comedy
so i could be more serious
about this what about that wasn't even a
personal email can you imagine what she
does on her personal emails
it's pretty scary what have you ever
seen this kind of stuff in your career
and you know what it is stuart barney
ever said emails like this
no he just yells at me and bursting but
no i mean in a corporate world wouldn't
you be fired for this type of behavior
yeah it's like tom cruise screaming at
the crew it just
it's just not acceptable in a bank or an
actual business there's something going
on there i don't know what it is i i
mean it's like
she can't be competent and it's to your
point it's like how did this ever happen
and we see this there's got it they got
it because it's this is a great city
yes this is a great city and it's just
like people are just writing it off
it's sad it's sad hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else